la presa de nueva cajofca en el sur de
Ucrania se encuentra a unos 30
kilómetros al este de gersón atraviesa
el río nieper tiene 30 metros de altura
r Tiene 18 kilómetros cúbicos de agua su
destrucción Podría tener grandes
consecuencias para toda la región
Empezando por las ciudades río abajo el
nivel del agua ya está subiendo
rápidamente las autoridades dicen que
seguirán subiendo durante otras 72 horas
antes de bajar han emitido decenas de
órdenes de evacuación más arriba se
encuentra la central nuclear de
saboricha el agua del embalse situado
detrás de la presa es necesario para sus
sistemas de enfriamiento el organismo
internacional de energía atómica dice
que está vigilando la situación pero que
por el momento no hay riesgos inmediatos
el sistema de riego por canales de
crimea Está también en riesgo el canal
del Norte suministra agua crimea desde
el río nieper
supone alrededor del 80% del agua de la
zona la destrucción de la presa dañaría
probablemente el sistema amenazando
120.000 hectáreas de cultivos